hey guys it is the six of November today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
tuned into games but news
CD Projekt RED has given us another
reason to keep them on our Christmas
card list this year by just announcing
16/3 DLC packs for The Witcher 3 the DLC
packs are available for every platform
and the first bundle will come out on
February 25 that's just one day after
the game's official release that
particular pack will give you the
temerian Armour set and the beard and
hairstyle set for girls if you prefer
him to look all distinguished and [ __ ]
after this point each subsequent week
will bring new packs with things like
quests and personalization options
next up Far Cry 4s PC specs have landed
and they're nowhere near as astronomical
as those for Assassin's Creed unity to
play the game on PC you will need a
64-bit OS but the rest of the minimum
specs aren't anything true demanding
they call for four gigabytes of RAM 30
gigabytes of hard drive space and an
NVIDIA GeForce GTX 460 or AMD Radeon HD
5830 the optimal specs require your
machine to have eight gigabytes of
memory and an nvidia geforce gtx 680 or
AMD radeon r9 290x or better let me know
if your machine can run it finally the
ps4 version of Call of Duty advanced
warfare is blocking the consoles share
play functionality this news comes just
a week after Sony claimed the feature
which allows two ps4 owners to play the
same single copy of a game over the
internet would work on all games the
plan is for the guest console and share
play to be able to take over control to
help with a level or what-have-you and
even though the sessions are limited to
60 minutes you can jump right back in
after the time has elapsed Activision
has marked all shared gameplay footage
as censored which keeps it from being
seen by another user the sensor option I
mentioned is intended for use to
circumvent spoilers from being revealed
to a guest console but it seems
Activision have gone and leveraged that
the whole game from being streamed to a
friend as a result sony has issued a
statement saying that not all games will
work with share play since developers
have a choice to opt out for their game
as for your question of the day let me
know if you think this is seriously
uncool by activision or is it fair
enough if you're after more stories you
can head to game set up for bits and
pieces on microsoft finishing their
purchase of minecraft and south park
parodying for you to play that is it for
me today do you remember if you put back
same time tomorrow you can check out the
5 biggest stories of the whole gaming
week I will see you then